so he already had a girlfriend but she
lived in Korea and so I was the mistress
but I wouldn't know that because she was
a side chick oh no she's Inc you know
what I mean but then I found
[Music]
out welcome back to another amazing
episode of careful boys today we have
with us some nectar hard Seltzer brought
to you by UTI boys and girl hey and one
girl
under the influencers Y go check out
their Channel under the influencer under
the influencers that's why we have to
make our name on Snapchat cuz they
wouldn't allow Under the Influence so we
just added the r at the end yeah yeah
it's so corny I hate it on Snapchat on
Snapchat what about what about on
Spotify and stuff oh everywhere else
it's fine Snapchat specifically wouldn't
allow something that like promotes drug
or alcohol use isn't that ironic even
yeah even though like you just added an
r and that was fine yeah okay cuz it
made it a whole different word under the
influencer so we just discovered we were
talking a lot about revenge oh yeah like
uh specifically like if something were
to happen between uh like we were
basically talking about Esther if
somebody grabbed her ass when she want
her man to defend her by beating this
guy up and we discovered that she has
Elite level empathy very very big
empathy and and then it it brought me up
to a a thing that Hannah told me she
goes you know why girls like bad boys
and I was like why she goes well okay so
Primal style good boys will probably do
everything legal to get you back if you
got kidnapped or whatever but what bad
boys will do is they'll burn the world
down to get you back so she's like then
I feel more protected by a bad boy
because they won't follow the rules to
they'll do whatever it takes they'll do
whatever it takes and then I and then
and then it was funny because uh Esther
was like actually I disagree yeah
because okay so I I'm you know I'm kind
of soft-hearted but if you get me angry
enough I'll [__] go off right and I
think that good
boys or you know like you know whatever
right good boys you know they may be
like soft and whatnot too but you know
if you push them hard enough and they
really have to do something they would
do it so like I'm saying that I don't
want a man that's just like ah you know
like super angry then I think we have a
different definition of a good boy okay
okay see that's the cuz I don't think a
good boy is capable of murder yeah I
want a levelheaded man because I think
that if a guy just acts on aggress you
know aggression then you're like you're
like a superhero that like just ruins a
whole [__] town just to beat one
enemy you know what I mean like you're
just aggressive sometimes that's what it
takes I age I agree with eser I also
like my men levelheaded yeah exactly
heard that you you're talking about more
like impulsive I think I know what
you're talking about it's like a it's
like a special ops guy right like he's
doing a mission but he's not doing it
like like just
out of yeah like a like a terrorist or
someone that's like a dictator who's
going to collateral damage but he's like
got a mission and he's in danger but
he's controlled I get it's hotter when
they're thinking and they're coming up
with the plan and I feel like uh when
you guys were talking about oh I like a
good boy or a guy that's doing things by
the law I'm like that's not a dumb thing
you know like why would you no I agree I
I I think we had a different idea of
what a good boy was yeah yeah but they
brainstorm isn't at all
costs like if you have a bad boy
brainstorming they're like maybe we have
to break through the wall or maybe I
have to break in jail to get my girl out
of jail whatever I think a good boy
brainstorm like there's a wall there
there security guards over
here oh what do I do cuz I would argue
that the the the image that you have of
a good boy is actually a bad boy too
these are different things you're
thinking of like a man that has has like
his emotions under control that could be
a bad boy or a good boy I think I see
what I feel like what what she's trying
to say is I want to say it's a dangerous
man who has self-control so a man who's
capable of doing dangerous things but
they're like a martial artist right they
they can train they're trained they can
they're like a [__] killing machine
but they don't go out and and just
because they're angry they beat
everybody up yeah that's good that's
good that's good yeah yeah but I think a
good boy in my mind isn't even capable
of violence because it's like a nice boy
it's like a someone who's like afraid
and will stand like just like he would
like a guy slaps your ass and he'll be
like you shouldn't do that like he'll
try to he'll try to dissolve everything
with words cuz he's afraid of
Confrontation okay okay you're get mad
at you okay you know what you're right
you're right [__] that [__] that yeah
cuz the level-headedness could be across
both in my so maybe the definition is
not so good boy bad boy it's more like
the idea of a bad boy is someone who's
capable of dangerous things and and yeah
they have the the the the aggression but
they don't use it all the time see now
that that's cleared I'm like yeah hell
yeah I would want a bad boy but you're
also you also are a little bit of a
unique perspective because your reflex
was not to say go get him babe it's like
you are going to do something about it
yourself first right I'm a very strong
masculine woman yeah yeah so if you were
like groped at the club or whatever like
you were like I'll [__] do it yeah
I'll [__] do it yeah seen her beat
grown men in arm wrestling what the [__]
and she does not work out ever well I
was a wrestler in high school and a
kickbox that means Jen is just weak bro
that's why dude the wrestlers the
wrestlers always why'd you wrestle in
high school that's a weird sport to the
[__] H it it was like a it was like a
joke thing cuz like but didn't you do it
two years I did for a year and like I
was good at it so I was like I'll keep
going that was a joke I would never live
it down if I lost a match to a girl
honestly and she was joking about it too
no the thing was so so my friends always
knew I was strong but then you know how
when they announc it like oh we have
wrestling practice H come come to the
room whatever right my friend was like I
bet you won't do I was like why the [__]
would I do that you know and he was like
oh you know I bet if you do this blah
blah blah like you just made a BET right
and I was like all right and I went to
the room the I was quite girly you know
I was wearing a dress and I went there
and then the teacher was like um
cheerleading is that way and I was like
no I'm here for wrestling and then like
that kind of got me like
you have no idea
yeah I I was like okay all right so then
I stayed and then I actually showed up
to the practice and he was like oh
you're serious about this and I was like
yeah every single time you would make
remarks like that cuz I'm very
competitive back in the day now I'm lazy
as [__] but back in the day I was very
competitive so I was like now I want to
go and do my [__] right and so I I
proved myself and then I went to
championships wow damn dude you were
winning matches damn were you wrestling
against chicks or other dudes uh
sometimes chicks because I I I was 120
and there's like skinny boys so I would
have to wrestle boys and girls damn and
you're just washing these little scrubs
oh you know what we probably would have
wrestled I was 120 in high school I was
also 12 I was 126 see I'm telling skinny
Asian boys dude I'm not going to lie I
I'm 12 now I'm stronger than all girls
but men even at 120 they're Stronger
Yeah they are just testosterone they may
be skinny but they're strong wiy but
also yeah at 122 there's like zero fat
percentage on them so it's like a very
efficient body you know what I mean and
they're fast too like I wasn't fast I
was 120 they're usually short sometimes
like they're like 51 and still kind of
jacked like I used I was like so I'm
like 5'8 and I'm like sometimes I'm
wrestling some dude who's 5'2 I'm like
your arm is like the size of my
waist and then they would just toss me
around yeah you wrestled all through at
high school I only did I did two years
so I had to like go to like a criminal
boarding school after juvie and then so
when I finally got back to real life it
was like junior year and then I was like
what am I good at I don't have any
skills cuz I was away and then I was
like I liked fighting I feel like
wrestling could could be similar and it
was just not similar at all cuz there's
like a hell of rules but uh it was like
the that made me get into like Fitness
and working out though cuz I realized
like that [__] that [__] is hard as [__]
I was telling him I'm pretty if I
remember correctly I think I lost a
wrestling match to a girl in high school
it was
me so it's coed in high school it is
coed wrestling is a coed sport like when
I was wrestling her like I didn't know
where to put my hands like I felt weird
I had to wrestle a girl in high school
too oh cuz you're in singlets and stuff
so you never trained against the girl no
that was the first time you ever had to
do we went to a different school and I
wrestled two matches that night and one
of them was with a girl I felt mad weird
I knew the power of women when I did
Judo as a young boy and I was like bro I
get tossed around like a little rag doll
I kind of like it so your friends [__]
me up too so then on the flip side on
the flip side for you for all the guys
is it attractive for your girl to get
mad at another girl that did something
to you no no it's got to be the same
scenario I got kidnapped and I need her
to [__] burn the world down yeah I
want that I mean I dated nothing but
abgs and like feisty women growing up
because I felt that that was like I like
a girl that can handle themselves and
not look for me to help them I like
being the one to helped the girl yeah
but I don't like I don't want that
doesn't mean I want a helpless woman but
like I do I think the Feist is
attractive cuz it feels like you care so
much that you're going to you're going
to [__] kill the woman that tries to
what I like is the same attitude but
channeled differently so like in Game of
Thrones I like Cersei Lannister because
she'll do whatever the [__] it takes to
protect her family she'll do anything
like wait who's that one is that the
she's the one that blew everybody up the
bald lady she's the [__] brother
[__] the shame lady she's not the one
that was a Terminator right the mom and
Terminator oh Sarah Conor she was the
one no she's not the one that was
getting no that's Daenerys yeah yeah
she's the one yeah the one that got
[__] in the tower oh yeah the older
lady a yeah she's so I like her because
she's not physically going to be the
ninja but she'll make sure that she
knows what she she's like political
determination yeah yeah but she's evil
though I don't know if I want my triick
doing all that like blowing up a blowing
up a building yeah not evil but the the
that same like scorched Earth mindset of
like if I was in jail she does whatever
she can but still have the same attitude
I like would you prefer Cersei as your
wife or um what's the [__] Ned
Stark's wife's name oh she was awesome
too I forgot her name which one start oh
you're talking about cat cat yeah yeah
yeah so like I feel like complete
they're both like super motherly and
protective of their families but one's
like objective good and one's like
objective bad so which one but I mean
one lasted longer and she has more
actually all her kids are dead everybody
lost their kids and everybody died cat
with
cers I feel like cat younger would
probably still be bad I think what I
liked about girls that seem like they
can handle themselves is I know that I
can't always be there so when're of mind
yeah I don't feel like oh my God where
is she you know is she okay she's alone
versus like oh you guys are in danger
she's crazy you know what I mean
wait why did you say that I was crazy
when you want when I said that I was
possessive and you want a girl I don't
want a girl that does that no no you
said didn't he just say that he likes
girls I don't remember that at
all that I don't think he said anything
he said he likes the feisty yeah I like
I think no I was just more like
analyzing why anyone would or like why
even I might find that attractive but
overall like when it really comes down
to it in the flirting stages I'm like I
like it when they're like who's that
other [__] oh it was your other
girlfriend or like that type of [__] are
you guys are you guys indirectly
flirting what no no no no this guy hell
no no no no no no they both look so
disgusted dude say that you just had
siblings
flirt but [__] um what the [__] was I
saying [__] everything up dude I
[__] everything up [__] now dude
this is CIS right here is it is it uh
like a damzo and distress thing you like
no because but you said in the flirty in
the FLIR
you like the energy in the flirting
stage it's cool and all cuz it's like oh
you barely know me you want me and then
like the second it starts to get further
that [__] is annoying like without fail
every time so like I feel like I was
always like I end up dating girls that
do that cuz they cuz I'm like oh this is
cool right now and then without without
fail every time it's like oh God agreed
I am annoying you're very annoying
honestly I yeah I'm trying to stop thank
you this is why Jeremy will never love
you no I dead ass I learned a lot on
this
podcast and I she completely changes her
personality and now I know that if you
want to cheat Go cheat wait would you
actually are you actually going to
change that part of your social media
strategy yeah yeah that's cool that's
cool but the key is you set up the Trap
so you know I'm not going to go I'm not
going to go that far setting up the Trap
Is Wild I'm going let you do what you
want to do sending Jeremy
profile send a hooker I'm going let you
do what you want to do but the thing is
if you do it then I'mma I'm going to
make you pay actual money I just actual
money your ass you want to do you want
to allegedly tell that story or no oh
allegedly so my ex-boyfriend cheated on
me so I made him pay me
$10,000 in reparations payment literally
in payment CU he was poor but how do you
do that how do you even more impressive
well okay so actually okay let let's be
okay I'll be honest so how did you
allegedly how you do him or extort him
she probably has so much dirt they dated
no I didn't okay the only dirt okay it
was a pretty pretty big dirt so he
already had a girlfriend but she lived
in Korea and so I was the mistress but I
wouldn't know that because she was a
side chick oh no she's in Korea you know
what I mean but then I found out I found
out and then I got all of her
information in Korea and I was just like
damn I'm going to tell her because as a
woman I want I want her to know that her
man is Che you know what I mean slay got
paid for I thought no but I thought
about it I was just like I feel like
judging by like their exchanged messages
I'm like she is obsessed with him and
they have family ties and I'm thinking
that if I tell her I think that she may
go back to him so I was like might as
well I was like might as well benefit to
this you know like benefit myself that's
a good observation yeah so so then I was
like you know what if I tell her and she
still goes back to him I'm losing and um
let's make this a winning profit big
business brain that's great that's
wonderful I think it's great Y no this
the audacity of him so I said you know
what talk talk to him talk to her right
now and tell her what you did you know
and and show her proof so like she knows
what you did and he was like no I'm not
going to do that and I was like well
then I'm going to tell her and he was
like you don't know her information I
was like yeah I do and then sends her
his I literally yeah I literally had all
the information and then he was just
like um and I was and then I was like
yeah or or give me money and he was like
how much and I said $10,000 oh you
started at 10K 10K and then and the
[__] had the audacity to be like
I don't have that much money what about
5k I'm like he Tred to bargain I was
like you really on my bed right now
trying to bargain with me did did he
have should have been like $1 15 did you
know his finances like to know yeah yeah
yeah he made like $60,000 a year he was
like a like a chef how did you pick 10K
though how do you find how do you come
to that no you know the thing is I
picked an absurd amount of money because
I wanted him to tell her and then
instead he de he was down to pay he was
down to pay and then I just let that
ride you know what I guess the money
wasn't as absurd I should have been like
20K you know I really wanted him to tell
her was there a document or something
that that will yeah we had a contract I
actually actually called I actually
called my lawyer who happens to be my
friend so he wrote like a fake ass like
contract allegedly wrote the contract so
like it but that' be fine no you signed
it it made him it's more like mental
thing like you sign something it makes
you feel like literally like a random
CPA that will not be named gave the
advice of like oh like like my boy's
like business you had to fire somebody
that was just like being a piece of [__]
and then he was like listen just make
him sign this he's like okay Bet get
some to sign he's like what does this do
he goes nothing but he just signed a
piece of paper and now he thinks he's
Bound by some piece of paper and it
worked like the guy did nothing after I
am so cheap I would have
told I'll be like I hope you forgive me
um I I had a side chick and then I'm
like baby they're going to charge me
10K how about this we I keep that CH 10K
we go on a cruise and we make this all
better that's what I wanted him to do
because I was just like [__] I felt so
bad for the girl I really did because I
I would have never done it if I knew
that he had a okay let's get to the good
part what did you do with the 10K yeah
yeah what' you buy yourself did you go
to not B it on black on a silver bullet
I I went gambling with it yeah wait
wasn't it in like payment installments
too it was payments cuz he was so poor
dude he paid me like $2,000 the first
month and then he paid me $1,000 uh
every month or other month and then like
for some reason the payment started
slowing down right he missed the payment
dead a thug so on the contract it says
that if you don't pay the full amount
you have to give me your car but then
what you had stipulations too let's be
real I didn't want his car he had a
Genesis and it wasn't even paid off o
Janice's baby oo so no no I mean I'm not
saying it's a bad car I'm not saying
it's a bad car I drive a toy camer I'm
just saying that it wasn't even paid off
so why the [__] would I want it like it
was like a burden yeah it was a burden
you know what I mean and so I was just
like damn we're you know but I honestly
wasn't even mad at him anymore I was
just like I hope he learned this lesson
cuz this is like nine months later with
like $77,000 passive income dude that's
sweet so he had a he had a date that he
had uh should have been his last payment
so like I was like by July or something
like that I have to read over the
contract wow but but basically yeah it
was like June or July is right and he
was late and he actually text remember I
told you he texted me yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then I just said you're good oh
no way she absolved him of his payments
cuz I was dude I you're so nice I like
mad I wasn't mad after like two days I
wasn't mad you should have been like oh
you know scario please what if he did
this what if he goes you know what I'm
actually in love with you I'm going to
break up with her right now hell in
front of you and then he he went speaker
phone and he goes like I know you're in
Korea but
bye-bye no no no I didn't want like I
don't want anyone that no if you're
doing that type of [__] yeah you're
you're scum I find it so weird that he
didn't put a stipulation in the contract
that says in the case that you end up on
a very famous podcast you may never tell
this story public cuz that's kind of
like telling it he didn't write the
contract said he actually said like um
uh don't talk about it and I said Why
That's not in that's not in the contct
not in our contract that's not in the
contract contract cont he did ask me for
something though he said that if I do
give you the money then your friends
cannot harass me your like gang member
friends cannot come to my house and like
rob me he just lit let me get a shout
out let me get a shout out on IG cuz
he's met he's he's met my friends
they're scary no they're nice they're
super nice but you know what I mean like
he but they're your friends yeah they're
nice to you it's like a pit we all know
where he lives so you know what I mean
like yeah so he was just like taking
precautions right he's just taking
precautions so that was part of the
contract so obviously like when my if my
friend was to ever run into him i' they
can't I I would I told all my friends
and it was on the podcast I they're just
like if we didn't have that
contract they run up on him like oh but
you guys he didn't py swear with them he
has to py swear and lock it in but you
guys it's it's it's a word you know like
it's a word I have to keep my word so
you're an honorable Thug I love that
that's awesome okay honorable gangster
she's literally a thug though no but
what don't you have
done I side with you because it's he's
been lying to you he [__] it you know
I think I think he should have paid more
than that and then I don't think he's
broke 60k a
year what 10K come on I don't think dude
in LA and then you let him and you let
him go with the last payment but I guess
if you're not mad at the end of it yeah
then it's like okay you should have
added interest for late payments and
[__] no I was going to or like you see
him at the club on the story like I
think you I think you let him off easy
yeah you think so a lot of people
thought I was crazy for that well I'm
not normal and then I had to explore
them for calling me crazy just it's just
how it work would you be sad if you
found out later that he didn't have the
money and he was getting it from that
girl the whole time to pay you man lowy
I think she's balling to that's why he
he was like yeah my wife got me my
future wife got
me so no you wouldn't be bad would I
would I be
sad honestly till this
day I actually not to this say I'm not
that nice um I I'm over it I'm over it
yeah I feel like if someone's scummy to
you then they're fair game that's my
that's my feelings I don't believe in
Vengeance but I believe in Justice I
believe in Vengeance yeah I don't want I
don't want yeah I feel like that like
vengeance is more like taxing to you
like for you to be wronged and then you
have to sit there and care about it over
and over to get them back yeah that's
why I wasn't mad like after 2 days of or
two days I wasn't sad I wasn't mad I was
just like damn theud it of this guy you
know but then other than that no I
wasn't mad at him at all and then
whenever I would actually feel bad when
he came to give me the payments because
he'd be like Esther are you home I'd be
like I'd be like no I'm not home but you
could drop I'd be like drop it off in
the mailbox you know and take a picture
of it that was that was it damn it was
all in cash too no no no funny business
no paper Dr yeah that's so funny you see
the video of him walking away like his
clothes are all
tattered yo but you wrote me a three
page long note of saying like dude it
was It was kind of sad honestly what was
the note the note damn I wish I bought
it so you guys can put it up but it it
was really it was honestly really sad
exposing his not it was like it was like
umone going to recognize the handwriting
he said that he has like a this routine
in his life he was like all I did in
life was go to work come home sleep go
to work and he was like I felt like
there was no light in my in my world
until you came in I was like he's trying
to win you back no no no I was just like
I was just like oh why' you [__] that up
then that would have worked on me
no no because I mean even if you're sad
that's not you shouldn't do that so I
the guy with a hondai Genesis are you
sure he's sad that's living
baby yeah and then he was like and and
honestly I shouldn't have done that but
when I whenever I hung out with you I
felt really happy and I let that greed
get to me and I'm sorry and he wrote
like a long ass letter he was like I
didn't mean you any harm but I did and
I'm sorry for that and so he was like
pretty genuine about it from what I am
reading that kind of nice so he was like
two girlfriends he literally said I will
pay you back every single penny until
like I make it right to you and then I
was just like yeah he's taking
accountability and now that I know your
empathy level I could see that letter
actually affecting you I would have been
like you con artist you [__] are you
born a liar you're still lying in this
letter [__] you that's how I would be ly
the letter was so good I thought he
might have written it to multiple women
wow it's like the fifth draft it's the F
this was third time being extorted mine
was mine was the perfected perfected
like that was the final one it's like
one of those like my letter
to one of those messages broke he has
three other girlfriend yeah or this is
the first time and now he knows how to
get out of all of them if he gets caught
he's like hey I'll just give you eight
grand he has to go find another
girlfriend to help him pay off the
depths from his last girlfriend help him
write another letter I mean that is a
pretty Elite move having a whole other
relationship isn't some oopsy thingy
that's like kind of very well crafted
you have to choose to date somebody
again how long are you guys dating deep
in it we're dating for a month shut the
[__] up you got you're like all right a
month he paid 10K for a month dude
that's nothing but net dude you're
pulling from half you serious it's
really a month you have a year passive
income for one month did you also not
like you guys even [__] yet or like have
sex what oh my goodness you got no [__]
oh my goodness just kidding news careful
boys is a brand just kidding news is the
man of smart people the people of just
kidding news careful boys they are very
smart just kidding news the number one
forcast in the
world
he